vous nous avez demandé pourquoi le prix
du céleri at il explosé en épi c'est en
effet le pied de céleri se vend
actuellement libre est aussi fou que 5 à
6 dollars
il ya plusieurs explications à cela
d'abord les mauvaises conditions
climatiques et la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ont forcé les agriculteurs a
diminué leur production de 50% mais
surtout depuis quelques mois le jus de
sellerie est devenu un aliment à la mode
il ya de nombreuses stars d'hollywood et
du web qui vendent sur les médias
sociaux les soi-disant bienfaits du jus
de céleri pour la santé ce qui a fait
exploser la demande tel point que la
production californienne ne suffit plus
il faut maintenant importer du céleri
d'espagne par avion résultat le prix du
céleri ne baissera pas à court terme
merci gwyneth il faudra attendre
l'arrivée du céleri de l'ontario et du
québec début juillet pour que les prix
retombent à la normale